a lot happens in the new borap movie a
sequel to the 2006 original that
launched leading man sasha baron cohen
into the spotlight with a hardy very
nice but there's one moment in
particular that has everyone talking
officially titled borat subsequent movie
film delivery of prodigious bribe to
american regime for make benefit once
glorious nation of kazakhstan the borat
sequel touched down on amazon prime
video on friday october 23rd to much
fanfare
after the world caught win that baron
cohen filmed the borat sequel in secret
reprising his role as the fictional
journalist from kazakhstan borat sagdiev
years after saying he'd retired the
character for good
fans were keen to see what the second
round of mockumentary antics would
entail
this time around after being released
from jail following the events of the
previous movie borat discovers that he
has a 15
year old daughter named tutar who he
wants to teach to become a perfect gift
for vice president mike pence
as the movie's title suggests this is an
effort to repair kazakhstan's reputation
matana bishfiel
[Music]
of course borat 2 features plenty of
jaw-dropping scenes and a hefty serving
of political and social commentary
the most controversial scene of all may
be one involving rudy giuliani the
former mayor of new york city and
current personal attorney of president
donald trump
the scene has now been uploaded to
youtube available for everyone to see
the moment occurs at the height of the
film's action and sees giuliani in a
scene with maria bakalova the actress
who plays fifteen-year-old tutar sagdiav
it's worth noting that in real life
bakulova is reportedly 24 years old
here bakalova's tutor is masquerading as
a journalist who admires giuliani and
who is nervous about interviewing him
they're gonna do great okay the
interview is held inside of a hotel
suite
when it's over giuliani and bacaloba
move to another room and giuliani sits
down on the bed while asking for
bakalova's email address and phone
number
many pats are on the lower back and
appears to lean back on the bed and
begin adjusting his pants after bakalova
adjusts his shirt
baron cohen in disguise then burst into
the room
she's 15 she's too old for you
as with the original borat movie much of
the sequel is comprised of real-life
interactions with people who don't know
exactly what kind of movie they're
involved in
considering that giuliani didn't know
that the interview he was involved in
was fake many have expressed concern
and outrage at giuliani's interactions
with bakalova according to page six
giuliani quickly called the police after
his encounter with sasha baron cohen was
over realizing that he was the victim or
as he described it the attempted victim
of a prank
he told the outlet in july 2020 this
person comes in yelling and screaming
and i thought this might be a scam or a
shakedown so i reported it to the police
he then ran away i only later realized
it must have been sasha baron cohen
i thought about all the people he'd
previously fooled and i felt good about
myself because he didn't get me
at the time giuliani even acknowledged
being familiar and even fond of the
comedian's work he told the outlet
i'm a fan of some of his movies borat in
particular because i've been to
kazakhstan
following the release of borat 2 and the
controversy that sparked around his
scene giuliani took to twitter to
address the situation defending himself
in a multi-tweet thread
he wrote the borat video was a complete
fabrication
i was tucking in my shirt after taking
off the recording equipment
at no time before during or after the
interview was i ever inappropriate
if sasha baron cohen implies otherwise
he is a stone stone-cold liar
giuliani continued arguing that the
content of the scene was exaggerated
through editing and is meant to be a
distraction from his involvement in the
us presidential race between incumbent
president donald trump and former vice
president joe biden
during an october 23rd appearance on
good morning america the same day
barratt ii debuted baron cohen responded
to giuliani's remarks saying
if the president's lawyer found what he
did their appropriate behavior then
heaven knows what he's done with other
female journalists in hotel rooms
it is what it is he did what he did
and uh make your own mind up um
it was pretty clear to us baron cohen
said he then added that he was quote
quite concerned for bakulova during the
scene which he was overseen from a
hidden nearby location
you know it's my responsibility as a
producer as well to ensure that
the lead actor is
is looked after bacalova on the other
hand assured that she didn't feel like
she was in any danger during the scene
with giuliani
i've always felt safe with our team with
our crew with sasha in my corner
i actually never felt that i've been in
danger
on the official twitter account for
borat sagdia baron cohen released an
in-character video addressing the
giuliani situation coming to the
attorney's defense
saying that he's coming to defend quote
america's mayor cohen is borat offered
up some likely unwelcome assistance
saying
what was an innocent sexy time encounter
between a consenting man
and my 15 year old daughter have been
turned into something disgusting by fake
news media
anyone else try this and rudolph will
not hesitate
to reach into his legal briefs and whip
out his subpoenas
overall this situation is both
unexpected and uncomfortable though
considering this is a borap movie we're
not sure how it could have gone any
other way
borat subsequent movie film is available
to stream on amazon prime video now
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you